[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Feiertag was im Sport los war das
erfahren Sie von Rudi Cerne hallo
schönen guten Abend unsere Themen
[Musik]
Ruf Paps franziskus eindringlich zum
Frieden auf anschließend spendet er den
traditionellen Segen Obi
endlich wieder vereint von wohl Tausende
nach Russland verschleppen Kindern
kehren 31 in Ukraine zurück
und mehr Mindestlohn wegen der Inflation
und steigender Löhne stellt
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil eine
deutliche Erhöhung genau Sicht
es ist der Höhepunkt der
Osterfeierlichkeiten der katholischen
Kirche und Papst franziskus nutzte die
Messe zum Ostersonntag um ein Kriege und
Konflikte zu erinnern und zum Frieden
aufzurufen ostern ist das wichtigste
Fest des Christentums zehntausende kam
zum Petersplatz in Rom Annette
hilsenbeck
ausgelassen ist die Stimmung auf dem
Petersplatz unter den Gläubigen die
gekommen sind um gemeinsam mit Papst
franziskus die Ostermesse zu feiern in
seiner Botschaft verbindet er die
Auferstehung Christi mit der Hoffnung
auf Frieden in den vielen Krisengebieten
weltweit
beeilen wir uns Konflikte und Spaltungen
zu überwinden und unsere Herzen für die
zu öffnen die am meisten in Not sind
beeilen wir uns wegen des Friedens und
der Geschwisterlichkeit zu beschreiben
leidenschaftlich bittet der Papst um
Hilfe für die Menschen in der Ukraine
und erwähnt auch jene in Russland
hilft dem geliebten ukrainischen Volk
auf dem Weg zum Frieden und ergieße dein
österliches Licht über das russische
Volk
erst vor rund einer Woche war der
Pontifex nach einer schweren Bronchitis
aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen worden die
Freude ihn jetzt wiederzusehen ist groß
[Applaus]
wir haben sehr mit ihm gelitten ihn so
angeschlagen zu sehen wir hoffen dass er
sich bald erholt begleitet durch unsere
Gebete
Unternehmen Menschen zu stehen und
wirklich sich gegenseitig vor Osten zu
wünschen weil ein sehr schönes Gefühl am
Ende spendet der Papst den
traditionellen Segen urbiert orbi für
die Stadt und den Erdkreis
jetzt Spiritus
mit meinem Herzen
es war eine Osterbotschaft des Papstes
die in Zeiten von Konflikten und Krieg
Hoffnung und Zuversicht verbreiten soll
das ist einen Frieden geben kann
und auch in Deutschland riefen die
Kirchen an Ostern zu frieden Versöhnung
und Gottvertrauen auf der Vorsitzende
der katholischen deutschen
Bischofskonferenz der Limburger Bischof
betzing sagte die Auferstehung Jesu die
an Ostern gefeiert werde setze der
Eskalation von Krisen und Gewalt eine
Eskalation des Lebens und der Liebe
entgegen die Ratsvorsitzende der
Evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland
Kurschus sagte kein Augenblick sei ohne
die Möglichkeit dass es durch Gottes
Kraft anders wird
und wir blicken in die Ukraine dort
gehen die Kämpfe auch über Ostern weiter
im Südosten des Landes gab es russische
Luftangriffe auf die Großstadt saporicia
laut Behörden schlug eine Rakete in das
Haus einer Familie ein ein Vater und
seine Tochter wurden getötet die Mutter
lebensgefährlich verletzt
und seit Beginn des Krieges seien fast
20.000 ukrainische Kinder nach Russland
verschleppt worden sagt die Regierung in
Kiew der Kreml behauptet sie seien zur
Erholung dort der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof geht von einer
Entführung der Kinder aus und hat
deshalb einen Haftbefehl gegen den
russischen Präsidenten Putin erlassen
einer ukrainischen Organisation es ist
jetzt erneut gelungen einige Kinder
zurückzuholen leinos berichtet
der Bus der Wiederkehr erreicht Kiew
nach einer gefühlten Ewigkeit sind 31
verlorene Töchter und Söhne wieder
daheim auch Bogdan fliegt seiner Mutter
Irina in die Arme
beide stammen aus dem lange russisch
besetzten
sechs Monate lang habe ich meine Mutter
nicht gesehen ich habe sie so sehr
vermisst
die Grenze zu Belarus Stunden vorher zu
Fuß erreichen die Entführten
ukrainischen Boden fühlen sich erstmals
wieder in Sicherheit für die meisten
geht ein Albtraum zu Ende
sagten uns dass wir adoptiert würden
Saschas Mutter hat sie gerettet über
Polen Belarus und Moskau ist sie zu ihr
in das russische Heim gereist um sie
herauszuholen viele andere mussten
zurück bleiben
fingen die anderen Kinder hinterm Zaun
zu weinen an es zerriss einem das Herz
mit dem Versprechen eines erholsamen
Sommercamps wurden viele der Kinder auf
die Krim gelockt doch aus drei Wochen
Ferien wurde dann ein Zwangsaufenthalt
im russischen heim
jeden Tag gesagt dass unsere Eltern uns
ablehnen und nicht mehr haben wollen
die Organisation save you crane setzt
sich dafür ein verschleppte Kinder aus
Russland zurückzuholen oft sei das
Problem allerdings sie überhaupt zu
finden
es gibt Kinder die in nur fünf Monaten
an fünf verschiedene Orte gebracht
wurden
sie gehören zu den ganz wenigen denen
die Rückkehr bislang gelang tausende
Kinder warten noch
Geringverdiener die den Mindestlohn
bezahlt kriegen können im kommenden Jahr
auf mehr Geld hoffen
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil hat eine
deutliche Erhöhung in Aussicht gestellt
bei seiner Einführung 2015 betrug der
Mindestlohn 8,50€ pro Stunde seitdem ist
der mehrfach angepasst worden auf
zuletzt 12 Euro im vergangenen Oktober
darauf hatte sich die Ampelkoalition
verständigt und jeder fünfte
Beschäftigte hat von dieser Erhöhung
profitiert Heike berichtet
arbeit muss sich lohnen sagt der
Bundesarbeitsminister deshalb sollte
auch der Mindestlohn angesichts hoher
Inflation und Energiepreisen demnächst
steigen wenn was wichtig ist für den
Mindestlohn im letzten Jahr auf 12 Euro
erhöht haben aber er wird und er muss
weiter steigen dazu wird mir die
mindestlohnkommission im Sommer
Vorschlag machen und ich rechne mit
einer deutlichen Erhöhung eine konkrete
Zahl nennt der Minister nicht denn das
ist Aufgabe der mindestlohnkommission
politischer Einmischung so Vertreter der
Arbeitgeber entsprechend scharf ihre
Kritik aber das Arbeitsminister
sabotiert die Arbeit der
mindestlohnkommission und hat uns ein
ziemlich faules Osterei in die
Kommissionsarbeit gelegt an sich war die
Zusage dass der Eingriff der Politik
einmalig sei das war schon eine Zumutung
jetzt kommt der Bundesarbeitsminister
und legt uns schon das nächste Ei ins
Netz
Sozialverbände fordern bereits 14 Euro
die Stunde höhere Löhne führten zu hören
Preisen waren die Opposition im
Bundestag ich glaube bei aller
Berechtigung dass auch die unteren
Lohngruppen angesichts der hohen
Inflation zu ihrem Anteil kommen müssen
dass man nicht vergessen dass das
Auswirkungen auf das gesamte Lohngefüge
haben würde und damit eben die
lohnpreisspirale weiter in Gang gesetzt
wird und diese Debatte wird jetzt erst
beginnen aber wir brauchen ganz klar
eine deutliche Erhöhung des Mindestlohns
die Inflation betrifft ja alle Menschen
und vor allem die die den Mindestlohn
verdienen und deswegen muss der
Mindestlohn auch entsprechend steigen
Rückenwind des Ministers für etwa 7,5
Millionen Beschäftigte die vom mindestum
Leben auch wenn die Kommission für die
Lohnfindung als unabhängig gilt
nach Japan lange hatte sich das Land
militärisch zurückgehalten das ändert
sich jetzt grundlegend denn rundum tun
sich Gewalt Bedrohungslagen auf Russland
im Norden im Westen Nordkorea das mit
Raketen provoziert und vor allem China
der mächtigen Nachbar Tokio plant
deshalb seine Militärausgaben auf zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsproduktes
anzuheben das wären knapp 300 Milliarden
Euro in den nächsten fünf Jahren eine
der Militärbasen die aufgerüstet werden
soll ist amami ushima eine Insel im
Pazifischen Ozean von dort berichtet
Elisabeth Schmidt
im Ernstfall muss jeder Handgriff sitzen
Japans Soldaten trainieren einen Angriff
Chinas mit modernster
flugabwehrraketentechnik
dann Kriegsschiffe vom Meer aus
angreifen brauchen wir Raketen um sie
auszuschalten auch Attacken aus der Luft
können wir auf diese Weise abwehren
unsere Übung spielt das Szenario durch
das genau das passieren könnte
die knapp 600 Streitkräfte auf arami
trainieren auch regelmäßig mit Truppen
aus den USA das soll vor allem China und
seine Kriegsflotte abschrecken
zahlenmäßig die größte der Welt zur Zeit
probt die Volksrepublik einen Angriff
auf Taiwan im Staatsfernsehen heute eine
detaillierte Animation dazu
macht das große Sorgen der Reis Pharma
befürchtet Japans Aufrüstung könnte
China weiter provozieren
es muss nur ein kleiner Zusammenstoß
passieren auf See vielleicht auch nur
aus Versehen das macht mir am meisten
Angst dass ein winzig kleiner
Zwischenfall einen Krieg auslösen könnte
den Pazifismus hatte sich Japan
eigentlich in die Verfassung geschrieben
doch jetzt trainieren die
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte auch
Gegenschläge
China Nordkorea Russland Japan sieht
sich von unddemokratischen Staaten
umzingelt und vollzieht die radikasste
Kurswende seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
Japans Hawaii werden die Inseln rund um
amami genannt in diesem Paradies leben
sie mit der Kriegsgefahr jeden Tag
und wir kommen noch mal nach Deutschland
da hat diese Woche der Vorverkauf des 49
Euro Tickets begonnen und die Nachfrage
ist offenbar groß allein bei der Bahn
wurden in den ersten drei Tagen
250.000 Tickets verkauft der Konzern
rechnet insgesamt mit rund 17 Millionen
Nutzern und NutzerInnen darunter etwa 6
Millionen neu Abonnenten und
Abonnentinnen
und Regionalverkehr
ein Osterspaziergang bei blauen Himmel
für viele Menschen in Hamburg wurde
daraus nichts stattdessen Schritten die
waren Apps und draußen wurde es düster
eine gewaltige Rauchwolke trieb Richtung
Innenstadt ausgelöst von einem Großbrand
der mehrere Lagerhallen zerstörte
Steffen Wachs berichtet
meterhohe Flammen schwarzer Qualm und
immer wieder Detonationen
kurz nach vier heute morgen in einem
Gewerbegebiet brennen Lagerhallen unter
anderem mit Kühlschränken und
Waschmaschinen vermutlich auch
Chemikalien
das waren helle Wolken dunkle Wolken
graue Wolken dann solche Feuerbälle nach
oben Bahngleise werden gesperrt der
S-Bahn-Verkehr eingestellt und Züge
zwischen Berlin und Hamburg umgeleitet
aus dem Qualm lösen sich ascheklumpen
die Feuerwehr warnt vor einer Rauchwolke
die Stadt einwärts zieht und
möglicherweise noch andere
gesundheitsschädliche Stoffe enthält
über warm-apps werden Anwohner
aufgerufen Fenster und Türen zu
schließen der Brandgeruch spürbar in der
ganzen Innenstadt gegen Mittag eine
erste Entwarnung
wir haben nach ausführlichen Messungen
die Gefahrenmeldung von der höchsten
extremsten Gefahrenstufe runtergesetzt
auf eine gefahrenen Informationen so
dass wir nach wie vor für den Brandrauch
warnen aber zusätzliche giftstoffe
werden nicht gemessen nach Angaben der
Feuerwehr ist der Brand inzwischen unter
Kontrolle die Löscharbeiten laufen noch
erst danach kann auch die Ursache des
Großbrandes ermittelt werden
und den Sport beginnen wir mit einem
Spitzenspiel der Handball Bundesliga
ablösen würde der THW Kiel und der SC
Magdeburg haben sich dann in einem
Handballkrimi mit einem 34 zu 34
Unentschieden getrennt
wir sind hier nicht für Unentschieden
hergekommen sondern zum Sieg ein Pass zu
viel beim letzten ballbesitzt das Tor
zählt nicht Endstand 34 34 Kiel wieder
Tabellenführer vor Berlin und Magdeburg
und die deutschen Handballerinnen haben
in Hamm das erste Playoff
Qualifikationsspiel zur Handball WM
gegen Griechenland mit 39 zu 13 gewonnen
beste Werferin im DHB-Team war Julia
mythoff von der SG beteigheim mit sieben
Treffern das Rückspiel um das Ticket für
das Turnier Ende des Jahres in Dänemark
Norwegen und Schweden findet kommenden
Mittwoch statt
das Ergebnis vom ersten Sonntagsspiel in
der Fußball-Bundesliga Mönchengladbach
hat das Heimspiel gegen Wolfsburg mit
2:0 gewonnen und in der Deutschen
Eishockey Liga hat Ingolstadt die Adler
Mannheim mit 4:1 geschlagen und ist in
der Halbfinal-Serie damit mit 3:2 in
Führung gegangen
Vorjahresfinalisten München benötigt
ebenfalls nur noch einen Sieg um wieder
die Endspielserie zu erreichen denn der
EHC schlug Wolfsburg mit 3 zu 2 den
entscheidenden Treffer erzielte Patrick
Hager in der vierten Minute der
Verlängerung
die Cracks das war's danke Rudi und so
wird das Wetter das bringt im Osten am
Vormittag noch etwas Hochnebel sonst
zunächst vier Sonne später ziehen von
Westen Herr Wolken auf und gegen Abend
fällt Regen bei 14 bis 19 Grad wird ein
lebhafter Südwind
um 21.45 läuft das heute journal mit
Dunja Hayali schönen Sonntagabend noch
[Musik]